[Music]
foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
I'm piss Morgan on censor tonight a
royal apology in the Netherlands Sparks
yet more demands for British Royals to
atone the colonial sins As Americans
celebrate independence on the Davis now
accused of racism should we celebrate
our glorious past and present even if
it's flawed or just keep saying sorry
for everything or debate
Australia's Cricket treachery becomes a
diplomatic incidence of Aussie PM tells
us to stay in his crease and Minister
the British crown Into The Fray on
uncensored and I finally found that
Australian willing to debate me
but she's a controversial YouTuber who's
racked up Legions of followers by
claiming divorce would be illegal and
women shouldn't vote Hannah Pearl Davis
so she's the term of truth about
feminism but is she she joins me live
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored well
good evening London welcome to Piers
Morgan on census we're all grateful for
the police they're the men and women who
put their lives on the line to protect
us so most of the time that's what they
do from memory of your family went
missing someone threatened to attack you
if your home was in danger who would you
call well most of us would still call
the police and we still feel safer for
it but how about if you're burgled or
someone steals your car what if it's
Rowdy Behavior upset in the neighborhood
or a speed of thefts on the High Street
wherever you live there's a very strong
chance that many people have lost the
faith and the ability of police to do
anything about those kind of crimes and
incidents like this one in Sussex are a
major part of why a member of the public
reports a crime to a pcso who's sitting
in his patrol car less than 30 seconds
away from the scene his response is
frankly shocking all right you need to
get around to the co-op
honestly they've just been a fight round
there because people are trying to stop
the shoplifters that you're doing
nothing about
there's a member of public just being
assaulted by a 15 year old girl who's
drunk
had a drink thrown in her face got
punched people have called the police we
come around here and you're sitting here
I know you're not but the start of the
car will make them scatter
and you're afraid to deal with it then
it kind of is the point that's the
perception
that's just cowardice
no it is
I'm afraid it is
this is the whole reason these problems
exist
that that's a pretty poor attitude I'm
afraid
yeah it is it's hard to disagree with
anything that motorist recorded that
video said looks like a terrible
attitude does look like cow it is or
that's even worse disinterest as a crime
is literally being committed round the
corner and it sounds like how many
people feel about the police these days
that they don't care about Petty crimes
even if they do but none of the
resources or the ability to deal with
them every day now we see videos from
the United States of shoplifters quite
literally running riots robbers quite
literally taking calculators into shops
in places where theft below a thousand
dollars in value and now de facto legal
in the UK almost 600 burglaries a day go
unsolved 77 of all cases are closed with
no suspect ever being identified I had a
death rate made on my eldest son's
Instagram in public a specific death
threat and after an 18-month
investigation nothing happened
it's not good enough
I sympathize with the police I always
have done I think the vast majority of
police officers do a damn good job often
risking their lives to protect us but
the numbers and budgets have been
slashed they're policing with one arm
tied behind their backs and I feel sorry
for them for that there should be more
police on the streets we all know this
but if the attitude to the police you
are on the streets is to throw Loom the
towel and not even try then public
sympathy will very soon run out
okay well let me just start by my
regular nightly apology for the quality
of my voice this evening uh the world's
worst cold as always minor worse than
everybody else's is now entered day six
and my voice is now descending into
Barry White's little brother as I said
yesterday
um but I won't be seeing any love songs
unless you really behave yourselves so
none of the topic most beloved of
today's generation shame faced apologies
for all of our past the British Monarchy
is facing the new demands that it atones
for the UK's historic evils it follows
the decision by King William Alexander
of the Netherlands to say this
foreign
we carry with us the horrors of slavery
in the past the consequences of this can
still be felt today in racism in our
society Mr President
today I stand here before you as your
king and as part of your government and
today I make these apologies myself
[Applause]
I feel them immensely with Heart and
souls
well today is of course the 4th of July
it's a day that America celebrates
because they booted we British out our
monarchy out our Mad King George dropped
the ball otherwise I would possibly be
king bears right now of the United
States of America so we don't obviously
celebrate it with quite such enthusiasm
over this side of the pond but amid the
hot dogs and fireworks even this day of
patriotic celebration and the states has
become divisive as a growing trend for
black Americans to celebrate Juneteenth
as an alternative to July 4th veteran
congresswoman Max Maxine Waters in 2021
claim the Declaration of Independence
wasn't for equality and it was only for
white men a comments were echoed by a
fellow Democrat Corey Bush who said
black people still aren't free so is
there something in all this should these
National institutions and occasions the
opportunities for reflection and apology
rather than celebration well joining me
now is best selling all through the war
on the western conservative Douglas
Murray a country music legend Lee
Greenwood and my talk TV contributor
Paula Ron Adrian and talked to be a
presenter Richard ties all right well
Estella panel uh Douglas let me start
with you you read a great piece this
week for the telegraph about this weird
Trend I agree with you I think it's
weird where we're being compelled to
just apologize constantly for everything
that happened in the past why are we
doing this
that's right it's a very strange Act of
masochism really and an act of masochism
carried out by people who don't seem to
know anything I mean people talk about
the British Monarchy having to apologize
for slavery it was King George III who
signed the anti-slavery act into law in
1807 Prince Albert gave one of the most
extraordinary anti-slavery addresses
when the British was still policing the
anti-slave trade on the high seas in
1840 to the anti-slavery league in
London all of this was addressed 200
years ago and today unfortunately
there's a kind of new type of malcontent
and usually also a huckster to boot who
just decides that the none of this
happened usually it's because they
didn't don't know it happened and as a
result they look at our history and
everything in our country right up to
just you know innocent pastimes like
cricket and they decide to name
everything as guilty and you know you
could do this to every one and to
everything but most civilizations and
cultures don't behave like this because
most of them aren't just masochistic and
so self-hating all right Paula good
evening your response to that
I actually agree with Douglas about the
fact that we don't know enough he's
absolutely right we don't know enough
and it's important that we do but part
of the knowledge is also understanding
the hurt and pain that were caused not
just about the good things it's not just
about the cherry picking and Wrongs are
not about being masochistic saying sorry
is not a bad thing saying sorry is
actually a very empowering thing to do
why does it matter that a bunch of
Royals now get forced into issuing
groveling apology who care how does he
change anything it doesn't do anything
in my estimation to impact on current
slavery where it exists around the world
it doesn't really make any difference to
institutional racism as we've seen in in
certain parts of society I don't know
what difference it makes it might make
people feel a bit better to see a royal
groveling but so what see I I don't
agree with you surprise surprise I do
think it makes a difference I do think
it makes a difference that people people
in power are heard to acknowledge pain
and hurt I do think it's important that
people in power have taken the time
whose pain and hurt are you talking
about it's not it's not people living
today these are going back hundreds of
years in some cases these crimes of
slavery and so on we all agree it was
outrageous it's been debated you know
really year after year after year we all
know this I don't think that people have
a lack of knowledge and I'm not quite
sure where the apology tour ends what's
the end game so the end game is about
the ability to understand the true
history not just the part of history
that we have been taught and that is the
difficulty so you're talking about who's
the apology for well the apology is for
me the apology is for those who have
suffered the apology is for those who
continue to struggle through colonialism
and free slavery and I do think that
it's important that royalty are coming
forward and saying we apologize for the
if we all say sorry today it was
terrible which we all know yeah can we
then say right that's done we're going
to look forwards we're going to be
positive we're going to celebrate our
achievements learn from our failures and
we're done with apologize absolutely and
so how are we going to learn from our
failures if we do not understand what we
did wrong you learn from your failures
because that's what we're doing at the
moment the sort of report you had from
man for your failures if you don't
report you did wrong if you refuse to
accept that you did because the the
Cricket Board the ECB they've just
produced a report they've reported some
of it was good some of it you can
criticize or question the point is we've
learned from that we're moving on we're
celebrating we're being positive
otherwise I'll tell you what it does it
depresses everybody it leads to it I
agree with that I think what it does
want to bring in Lee Greenman here who's
a big country star in America and he
wrote God bless USA one of the great
anthems celebrating the United States
it's July 4th obviously as I said at the
start here Lee we don't celebrate it
with quite such enthusiasm this side of
the pond we sort of take a view that Mad
King George dropped the ball a bit but
I'm happy for my American friends that
you have this day to celebrate you wrote
this great uh Anthem really for your
country
can we be proud of our country anymore
or is this kind of this desire to feel
this terrible regret about everything an
apology for everything does that Ma The
Pride how do you feel
well I'm going to go out in a limb here
and just say the people that I run with
and talk to and I believe me I tour
Across America all the time we do 140 50
days a year every dog house outhouse and
roundhouse and I talked to the American
public they listen to what I say listen
to what I sing I happen to be a country
music performer but I was born in
California spent 20 years in Nevada I
live in the south now and I wrote this
song because it was for Unity it's a
unity and for military sacrifice and
yeah America started as an interesting
Expedition and then an experiment and we
fought it out we fought each other in
the Civil War and said okay bury the
hatchet here the trouble is as we move
forward a lot of people try to change
history I'm okay with history I'm okay
with apologizing for what happened back
then but I agree with you that was back
then let's move forward let's move on
past that and let's not change history
and try to change what happened yeah I
completely agree um Douglas the problem
is we've forgotten how to be genuinely
proud of our great countries both our
America and United Kingdom two of the
greatest countries in the world it's
almost like every day now somebody
somewhere normally on the left the woke
left is queuing up to find a reason to
hate the countries and their histories
well it's it's a kind of grievance
competition your guests earlier just
tried to engage in it I don't know what
hurts she believes she's had from
slavery all of this was addressed two
centuries ago everything has
consequences all history has
consequences and ramifications but you
know if we were to play this fairly we
would at least look at all of the
countries around the world that engaged
in the slave trade who are simply not
interested in any form of reparations
that the the Ottoman Empire all the Arab
countries who not just traded far more
slaves than across the Atlantic but
castrated all the men so that there
wouldn't be any more African slaves in
after them they worked on the bone I see
no interest across Africa in paying
reparations for selling their brother
and sister Africans into slavery or for
working them to the Bone to the present
day there is slavery across Africa today
in fact there are more slaves in the
world today than there were at the
height of the transatlantic slave trade
so some of us are simply a bit bored of
hearing people ripping at closed wounds
and then crying lying about their hurt
or their presumed hurt because everybody
could do this a million Europeans were
stolen by North Africans over the course
of Decades of the North African Barbary
pirate slave trade where would you end
if you did that the answer is you
couldn't end because nobody is alive who
has actually suffered the hurt and
nobody is alive who did the wrong and
I'd make one other point if I may it's
always the countries that people want to
come to who are put through this
struggle session Britain like America
and France are among are the most
desired destinations for migrants
worldwide and have been for centuries
why is that it's not because we're
racist it's because we're better it's
because we're good it's because when we
see racism we actually call it out and
recognize it as a sin try finding that
across Africa try finding that across
the middle east or in China nobody would
hear so what we have is a situation
where the more virtuous countries are
presented as the worst countries it's
sick and most of us are tired of it
thank you Douglas I am so sorry that
Douglas is bored by the pain that has
come that's not what he said through
slavery he didn't say he didn't say it
but what you're doing there but hang on
it's not Paulie you're being very
disingenuous that's not what he said the
viewers aren't stupid they know they
know exactly what he said he's not
saying he's bored by the pain he's
saying and I think it's a perfectly
valid point the pain that people who are
alive today are claiming they're
suffering so what happened two or 300
years is not a real pain they're not the
ones who suffered what was going on two
300 years ago so in terms of justice for
all I mean I think we'd all agree that
well I'm not suffering from when the
Norman's invaded this country I'm not
suffering from what my ancestors went
through I noticed I've not been allowed
to respond all from the Romans in other
words where do you take this I mean
should I now be feeling okay what the
Romans did to this in terms of slavery I
can take it to 2015 when the slave
owners were common stated by the
government so I can take it to that what
is your personal thing and I can say to
you and I can say to you that I don't
think that apologizing is a bad thing I
think that apologizing for a wrong is a
good thing I think that the
um Dutch royal family have done a
fantastic thing in acknowledging I think
all right
I honestly think it'll make no
difference at all Richard before we
finish this all I just want to ask you
about what I talked about at the start
of the show this police video really
quite shocking what do you make of it
when a police officer in a car sitting
there is told there's a crime going on
around the corner and just says I I
would have to deal with it because it's
so shocking it's actually hard to
believe it's true it's as though someone
sort of made it up in some TV studio
it's unbelievable our police are better
than what we know they are so something
fundamental is going wrong with the
leadership with the training with the
confidence and the belief you know the
worst thing about the worst thing about
this video is I know so many people I've
just stopped calling the police about
local stuff right and what New York
found was that they called it the thing
the breaking Windows broken windows
policy right where if you look after the
broken windows the more serious stuff
absolutely looks after itself and we
have stopped looking after the broken
windows and that video confirms what
many people are thinking and therefore
what's happening is actually it is less
safe on our streets in other towns and
Villages than ever but the reported
crime numbers are going down because
people have given up calling now if you
want to have a police chief of Sussex
issuing a public apology for that I'm
all in for the public apology you know
what King Charles can join in too Paul I
know you want to silence me peers I'm
ready to hear what is going to make a
difference for racism I'm ready to hear
I'm really sorry
Romans did to my ancestors I want the
Normans and apologies for that I want
I'm going to return Vikings we're going
to return I want the vote I want the
Dame to apologize to apologize for
Sunday and I definitely want the
Australians to be apologizing for that
absolutely appalling incident on Sunday
thank you both very much indeed Douglas
Murray as always brilliant over in New
York thank you and thank you Lee
Greenwood and happy July 4th to you and
God bless the United States of America
has been great for Douglas great for me
great for you right and it's a a
wonderful country so even though I don't
particularly get the bunting out today
the reasons that you will understand I
do I hope you have a great day of
Celebration
take care guys all the best well that
says the next she's been called the
female Andrew Tate Pearl Davis has
picked up Legions of followers uh Hannah
Paul Davis of course that is uh uh for
her and send reviews but is she for real
we'll find out next
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
ERS has racked up a legion of online
followers and plenty of breakfast
newspaper coverage by sharing her send
reviews on modern feminism the New York
Post called her the female Andrew Tate
so she tapped into genuine female
pushback to the accessories of wokory or
is she just an attention seeker we'll
find out a moment but first let's take a
look at the clip of Center viral
a lot of people think I'm insane because
I don't think women should vote
everybody thinks I'm crazy for this
opinion if anything this is probably my
most extreme opinion ninety percent of
women have been on birth control one out
of three women has had one out of three
women has an STD uh average body count
is over five so that your average wife
has slept with over five people 95
percent of women are not virgins on
their wedding days so I understand the
complaint
okay well Paul John's been alongside
political journalist Ava centene he was
nodding furiously along there to
everything she heard right Paul you've
become it would be called the female
Andrew Tate how do you plead
well I take it as a compliment you know
I'm a fan of Andrew Tate of everything
he says
um it depends what we're talking about
but overall I think he's got a good
message I think he's good for young men
okay look you're talking about women
predominantly
um which is why you've got this big
following and your view is that modern
feminism is deeply flawed I would argue
a lot of your proposals like taking the
vote away from are deeply regressive why
would you want to remove just from
yourself the right to vote well um what
happened was I I had the same view right
um back when I started I was like why
I found out that only five percent of
women wanted the right to vote and I
couldn't figure out like why would women
not no it's true
at the time because they've been
conditioned by men to think that they
shouldn't have a vote I mean that's what
they say but you know I started reading
their writings right and what I found
out was that the reason a lot of women
advocated for it was because they
believed it was the beginning of the
breakdown of the family you know before
you became one in marriage 85 percent of
people were married and you know I I
hate to say it but they were right what
has happened 100 years later what's I
got to do with them having the vote well
it also goes back to responsibility
um
again men are 80 to 90 percent of the
military they run all of the
infrastructures that make Society run
so I just think if we want an equal say
in society then be equal do 50 of the
hard jobs be 50 of the military in the
US
um they're fine 250 000 if they are not
they don't join Selective Service which
is essentially the truth okay but on
specifically on the vote what would
having the right to vote have to do with
family cohesion for example well because
again before you weren't trying to
divide a family it was one family unit
you had one vote for the family I mean I
don't think it's good for a family to
have two votes Ava your mouth seems to
have dropped tonight now I know it's
just sort of a galaxy brain I feel like
you know the statute of putting down are
perhaps correct in some years they just
kind of don't really add up I mean just
just to take you back to the to the
women's writings that you've allegedly
read I mean absolutely
at the time that you're talking about
you know women weren't really allowed to
write they weren't allowed to go to
school
that's incorrect the first female
property the first female property owner
was in the 1600s the idea that women
couldn't work
it no the first no no the first female
the first female millionaire was in the
late 1800s so no it wasn't it was
self-made yes it was yes it was yes yes
what what law permitted that well there
was no law I mean there's always been
women that were influencers let's get on
to the vote so what I don't understand
is you know a part of your message I've
just you know I've researched you today
hang on a minute okay you know your big
push is that you care about men and you
don't think that men are getting enough
of a say hang on I haven't made the
point yet
um because of feminism okay what I
wonder is when you start making calls
out like repeal the 19th women shouldn't
be allowed to vote how is that helping
young men because these young men have
women in their lives they have mothers
they have sisters they have teachers and
they turn around they don't know how to
act around women because you're giving
them license to be misogynistic I
wouldn't call it misogynistic I say be
equal so again men do all of feminism
well then okay I'd love for the
feminists please apply for the oil rigs
please go do the hard jobs in society
they're open they're hiring because I
don't equate for I I don't think men or
women are equal until we do the equal
work so no no listen listen go go apply
to beyond the oil rigs go do go be a
plumber go be electrician go be on the
front lines of the military and then we
should have equal rights but until
feminists are willing to do that I don't
believe believe we should have the
freedom without the response okay well I
don't think that I'm physically built
for that you might be but I'm absolutely
wow you said you were a volleyball
player and so you've got more strength
than I do I don't think I don't have
more strength
I don't have more strength than the
average man but my again it goes back to
go be a plumber you want to be equal go
beat also but you don't want you want
divorce to be made illegal yes why yes
because I don't think what we have today
is really marriage What is marriage it's
For Better or For Worse for richer for
poorer in sickness and in health till
death do us part that's what marriage is
supposed to be but feminists have ruined
marriage for the people that actually
believe in marriage when there is a 50
divorce rate and the average man why is
that all done to the women though I I
didn't say that it was all down to the
women you asked why I want divorce to be
banned can I finish it yeah first so I'm
saying you know the people that believe
in divorce go be in long-term
relationships leave marriage for the
people that actually believe in For
Better or For Worse for richer for poor
in sickness and in health till death do
us part doesn't the sanctity of marriage
also rely on the women being a virgin so
you wouldn't be able to get married I'm
what do you what do you mean well you've
spoken quite openly about how you're not
a virgin and so if you want to preserve
that sanctity of marriage
I just think that you're upholding
standards that you don't know you know
and that's a fair that's a fair
complaint I wish I was but you know we
can't go back I don't know what you want
me to say but I just don't think yeah
that you get to be here and you get to
be paid for your views and you're
telling other women that they shouldn't
be allowed
okay if I may at some stage jump in
um isn't the whole point of being a
feminist though that women are entitled
to have their own views absolutely so
she's perfectly entitled to her views
yeah but you can't you might not like
but I'm here isn't she exercising her
rights as a are you a feminist no I am
not really no you know I wouldn't don't
go that time you don't want to be a
feminine no because I
really believed in equality but you guys
don't I would love for you there is an
oil rig hiring there is an engineer I
would actually love to see
seriously seriously there is a building
being built next to my building go do it
feminists but don't do it and me I'm
staying on the same time when you find
the man you want to get married to are
you saying you will literally you will
be with that man whatever happens the
rest of your life yes for for the
willing to leave marriages because
they're not happy this is not about
happiness the most important thing is
the children and the problem is we have
a modern society where it's me me me my
feelings leave when I feel like it
instead of doing what's best for the
kids either I gotta say
it's a little about listening to Andrew
Tate where some of it I really don't
agree with I don't agree with the vote
stuff when I have things like that I
think there'll be a lot of people
especially older generation women
perhaps who think you know what she's
got a point well I mean I believe in
agency so I think that if a woman is
going to look after her children they
divorce that's absolutely fine I also
believe in your right to speak your mind
about it what I don't understand
women could speak openly at this idea
that like women couldn't talk the last
500 years there have been women
throughout the American States
has been there have been women
throughout history that have read
written and been very influential in
society okay so this idea like women can
never do it what I don't understand
though is when it gets spiteful okay
because you put down a few arguments
that I think are perfectly like you know
they're kind of Evangelical in their
Christian but those are your right to
say it what I don't understand is when
it kind of seeps into this sort of you
call women fat you say that they
shouldn't have are those things you say
that
you know I mean the question is are they
fat yes or no the average American woman
is 170 pound that's pounds that's
objectively overwhelmed I mean let's be
honest we now celebrate morbid obesity
as some kind of body positively and it
is complete nonsense so actually on that
point again there's a bit of Truth and
this is the problem this is the problem
how have we come to celebrate morbid
obesity is body positive nonsense we're
not talking about Mobility so I was
actually watching your podcast earlier
and you you spoke to someone who was I
would say probably a size 12 and you
called her it fat a beast and a divorce
say she was fat obese I mean like I
don't know what to say this is the thing
women we don't want to live in reality
we don't want to say things that are
true was she fat yes was she a divorce
say yes these things are just objective
facts okay I'm gonna have to objectively
she insulted me first they always I'm
gonna have to objectively end the debate
but it was an interesting conversation I
think we should get YouTube Back
Together As a matter of urgency uh thank
you very much Paul thank you over I'm
censored next Johnny Mercer the veterans
minister on his quest to get every
homeless veteran off the streets by the
end of the year and what he thinks about
Australia's cricketing treasury which is
now a major International scandal
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
welcome back to PS4 when I said it's a
British veterans Minister Johnny Mercer
says he wants to end rough sleeping for
all exponentary Personnel this year the
laudable quest but not without
controversy Mr Mercer's been criticized
for suggesting today that some veterans
may be using food banks because of
personal decisions and bad budgeting I
spoke to him just before we came on air
well enjoyed by Johnny Mercer Johnny
thank you for joining me so you've had a
busy day yes we have first of all I
think the initiative you're doing is
brilliant and we're going to come to
that to rid homelessness for our
veterans seems to me a route one thing
for any civilized society to be doing
and I will come to that but you've
you've blown up on social media you know
this because of this comment you made
about food banks what service Personnel
should not be using feedback yes yes
absolutely correct so the reaction has
been quite strong uh you've been
trending at various stages on Twitter I
want to just play first of all what you
said to Kate Burley on sky this morning
look these are these are personal
decisions around uh um you know how
people
um are budgeting every month I don't
want to see anyone using food banks of
course I don't but we're you know we're
in an extremely difficult time around
the cost of living people don't choose
to use food bags you're saying it's it's
a choice whether they use them or not
it's not they're using them because
they're saying they have no other
alternative well in my experience okay
that's not correct so people have taken
this as you being
a little blinkered perhaps about why
people use food banks do you stand by
what you said this morning did it come
out the wrong way what do you want to
say about it because people will take
whatever they want to take from what you
say right I clearly said that service
Personnel should not be using food banks
that is absolutely correct that anybody
on a wage like that who has subsidized
food and accommodation should not be
using food banks and in my experience
that is not the case
there's nothing wrong with that that's
right people then take that and say I
think people should generally not use
food banks and they make a personal
choice that's not what I said so there's
no point debating that because that's
not what I said but what I said was
service personnel and I was very clear
with that but you said that people make
personal choices and what the
interesting about service Personnel yeah
and people have said the inference from
that is that they shouldn't be on food
banks they're making a choice to be on
them the criticism has been actually for
most people on food basis it's not a
choice it's a necessity to feed
themselves and their family so I don't
dispute that for the wider population
right and I come across and I work in
you know I visit food banks in my
constituency and I see the need for food
banks and some of our most complex and
uh our poorest uh communities without
shadow of a doubt but that's not what I
was saying this morning I was saying
service Personnel should not be using
food banks and they shouldn't on their
way to subsidize food and accommodation
they should not be using food banks if
any of them are please do get in touch
because I'll be able to help them but do
you genuinely think anyone of military
personnel
is using a food bank through personal
choice I think there is no requirement
whatsoever for anyone in the military to
be using a food bank
okay a guy called Fred Thomas who's a
former Royal Marines Captain uh he's
Stanley is a labor candidate MP for
Plymouth more view he said he's shocked
and appalled by the comments you made
and he says Johnny Mercer May well be
able to make budget adjustments on an
income of more than 150 000 pounds but
how could he not know that for so many
of our people no matter how hard they
work and how well they budget they just
don't earn enough to keep up with the
spiraling costs and the despair this
causes
well again I mean you know firstly it's
an individual who's trying to get
elected right and everyone on the other
side of the fence on this has taken this
to mean that I don't think anybody
should be on food banks and that's a
deliberate choice for them actually what
I was saying was if you're in the
military you shouldn't be on food banks
a very reasonable thing to say so you
know people use these opportunities
there's been lots of people today using
these opportunities to be totally honest
with your peers I just don't get
involved because I have got the energy
for it they're arguing about something I
didn't say they're trying to make a
political point I'm not interested I'd
launched a scheme today to end uh
veterans homelessness this is where
political debate is in the country and
I'm just not interested in it because
it's it's like a false silly little game
for people to put things on Twitter you
know I've got bigger things to do I've
got really important things to do I just
have any time for this nonsense I'm
afraid let's turn to Operation Fortitude
how many ex-servicemen and women are
actually homeless you know yeah so look
there's there's always been
conversations about how many homeless
Fashions there are in this country and
it's been a difficult thing to work out
because we have traditionally he not had
a real grip on Veterans data right so we
didn't even know how many veterans there
were in this country when I started this
job for the first time last year we got
it in the census right where you could
declare if you're a veteran so we know
roughly there's about 2.27 million
veterans in this country at the moment
of those about 13 000 people who
completed a survey who were in sheltered
accommodation about 1.8 percent of them
were veterans right so there's an under
representation of veterans in the
homeless Community
um and so clearly it is a manageable
community that we can deal with if we
can put in wrap around services and
Clear Care Pathways for these people to
get out of homelessness we can do it and
that's what we've done with 8.5 million
pounds worth of funding from the
treasury what time scale have you put on
this I don't want to see a single Home
Inspection by the end of this year and
uh if there is you know I again I'm
happy to go around and visit people and
find out exactly why that is so to be
clear that is a veteran sleeping rough
because of a lack of provision clearly
some people will want to sleep rough and
I met a yeah a man last week who wanted
to sleep
because they uh they for a number of
different reasons for from their uh time
and service I've met plenty of people
who want to go and live in the woods for
a week and you know if that's what they
want to do that's fine that's not what
this is about this about people whose
lives have become incredibly
uh difficult to addiction to debt
through substance misuse whatever it may
be and it's about getting them in
getting a roof over their head providing
those services and getting their life
back on track I've got a lot of military
in my family my brother's just retired
after 37 years Rose to to be a colonel
this issue of homelessness with veterans
it really stings with the military
because we shouldn't be having any
homeless veterans in this country should
we well it's a very kind of visceral
representation isn't it of people who've
served in the military and put their
lives on the line and then have full
enough do we care enough about them as a
country I think
to be honest things have fundamentally
changed under uh in the last sort of
four to five years so I came into this
because veterans care was not very good
right and I fought in Afghan in 2006
onwards and I came into this because I
was fed up with how my generation of
veterans are treated uh yes it's been a
fight I'm not going to lie to you but
the British people have always kind of
got it right they've donated Millions to
help for Heroes and people like that I
think the government's been a lot slower
it's been very difficult in that space
we've now got a veterans out of the mod
right so we have the UK's first Office
of Veterans Affairs something the
Americans and the Australians and Canada
Canadians did decades ago we have a
cabinet minister who is responsible for
veterans able to pull in all different
parts of government and make it work for
veterans so yes we are fundamentally
changing it but you know I want this to
be the best country in the world to be a
Russian not because I say so but because
people actually feel that right you've
put a time of skill on it again your
boss Richie sunac has had his own five
pledges and I interviewed him at the
start of the year he said come back at
the end of the year and Mark me as
things stand the report card isn't going
to be good because he's he possibly may
not hit any of those pledges yeah I mean
hang on a second Pierce because at the
beginning of this right when he made
those five pledges people were falling
out of themselves to say this is going
to happen anyway inflation's gonna have
we're going to stop the boats okay these
are actually incredibly difficult things
to do so inflation doesn't just fall you
need to do a series of measures to make
that happen and he is making progress on
those things you think he'll hit it yes
I do yes I do you know we're six months
in and it's difficult right it is
difficult solving migration is difficult
it's not easy halving inflation is
difficult and all these other things
right we're halfway through you know
we're super Keen to not people who are
doing their best in public service like
he is or like I am today I think if we
just take the gas off that a little bit
and actually see what these people are
if he was to fail on all five pledges by
the end of the year where does that
leave the Prime Minister I mean if you
set your stall well and your Premiership
buy five pledges I don't think that's
gonna happen because say I'm not
thinking about that I think he's going
to get there I think that we've been to
an incredibly difficult time I think the
last couple years been pretty painful
but personally and and for the country
uh but I think things have changed uh we
got a new guy here and he's clearly
extremely gifted and capable we need to
Rally around him he's clearly the best
individual to be prime minister and we
need to get get into that election and
win it he's come out batting very
aggressively to the England team over
bear Stones
Anton Anthony Albanese who's the
Australian prime minister's hit back
telling him to stay in his crease so
it's now a major diplomatic row clearly
the English all believe that we were
done in here uh the Australians all
believe that this was waning pommies who
should shut up where do you sit with
this story look I think uh uh he was by
the rules of the game obviously this guy
was out right but I mean these
Australians they were caught like
sandpaper in the books three years ago
and then they all cried when they got
caught and went home and all the rest of
it it's pretty embarrassing you're not
going to get any sort of you know
spirited sportsmanship out of that
you've just got to get to the next game
and give them a good pacing and that's
the way to get through it fine words
Minister good to see you thank you very
much thank you very much
for fighting talk there from the British
government uncensored next the act of
unsporting treachery has become a
diplomatic Ferrari are we just whinging
palms or did the Aussies cross a line I
finally found an Australian who thinks
that we are a bunch of whiners and is
prepared to debate me live that's next
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
treachery at Lords on Sunday by the
Australian cricket team the Australian
present turn has taken an equally bold
stand well against me take a look at
this morning's Daily Telegraph in Sydney
has dressed me Ben Stokes the Jeffrey
boycott and Richie sunac as giant babies
with the headline a wobbly lower lip
Suki Palms keep spitting the dummy well
I'm joined by Chief Cricket writer of
the Australian Peter Layla Wakita great
to have you on the show uh you were on
your podcast yesterday saying I've been
ignoring all messages from radio and
television I'm only disappointed I
didn't have enough time to go on Piers
Morgan so I'd have loved to have gone on
that it would have been very
entertaining well now's your chance to
see how entertaining is going to be
Peter uh right let me start with with
this I want to show you again what
happened just to remind everybody this
is what went down here we go
so another short ball
for those who don't play a lot of
cricket what's happening Johnny bairstow
doesn't even try and hit the ball he
just Ducks the ball goes over his head
he then scrapes his boot inside the
crease you see him here from this angle
so when he scrapes his boot he's
denoting the fact it's the end of the
over six balls have been bold They're
Gonna Change ends scrapes his boot
everyone in world cricket history knows
that denotes but the batsman is marking
his crease and then he goes up to walk
to his captain and at that point I don't
blame the wicked keeper Mr Carey for
what he did he instinctively threw the
ball fine the person I blame Peter is
your captain Pat Cummings and here's why
three years ago the Australian cricket
team were in total Global disgrace over
sandpaper gay I think you were pretty
sensorious yourself about it and here we
have a chance three years on the
Australian team to show that they really
have changed their spots and actually do
believe in the spirit of the game
sometimes overriding the basic laws what
happened why didn't Cummings withdraw
that appeal and bring Johnny bastard
back you don't in your guts feel
comfortable about what you saw dude
a hundred percent comfortable anybody
who plays qriket peers knows that the
over is not over until the Umpire calls
it over
um let's there's a lot of people making
a lot of noise about this and sounding
like you but uh there's Michael Vaughan
Michael Atherton NASA stain uh Andrew
Strauss four people who have won a few
things in common they capped in England
and they agree with Australia's position
on this it was out he was Dopey it was
dozy it was stupid well hang on on all
of those I agree with you he was out he
was Dopey he was dozy and he was from a
cricketing perspective stupid I don't
disagree with any of that I think what
my wider point though is that given
everything that the Aussies have been
through with the cricket team in the
last few years in terms of the spirit of
the game yeah right and downright
cheating frankly with a sandpaper gay I
don't accuse the team of cheating at
this time I didn't like the scenes in
the laws Pavilion it's not cheating but
I would I would equate it to what
happened with Trevor Chapel in think it
was 91 wasn't it when he when he was
captained by his brother Greg and they
were playing a one-day International
against New Zealand and Trevor Chapel
was directed by his brother to bowl the
last ball of the match where New Zealand
wanted six to win to bowl it underarm
and he bowled under him and he created
such a fury that even the older Chapel
brother Ian Chapel condemned it on the
commentary box Richie Banner called it
one of the worst things he'd ever seen
both Prime Ministers of both countries
condemned it uh in fact Muldoon the New
Zealand prime minister said that he
thought it was appropriate Australia
were wearing yellow shirts and so on and
they changed the law as a result isn't
this the same well you've got something
which is typically within the rules it's
in the laws of the game but everybody
felt uncomfortable and you cite all the
captains of England who defend it fine
the public to a man and woman I've
spoken to all think this was wrong
Trevor Chapel's Act was an extraordinary
act and I think we all condemn it this
is sorry just on that point Johnny
Johnny
on that one point Murphy's tweeted me
tweeted today that he thinks it was
completely Justified what Trevor Chapel
did so not everyone thinks it was wrong
all right that's moved that's our move
yes there's a joker in every pack
um Johnny bestow attempts the same
dismissals in the same very same test
match no he attempted it in the previous
team the same thing the batsman was out
of their crease he attempted to throw
down the batsman is taking guard outside
the crease and therefore he plays and
misses the wicked keeper has a
legitimate chance to stump him if he
took guard outside the crease bear so
clearly here scrapes his boot inside the
crease he clearly scrapes his boot
everybody knows what he's doing there he
is saying I'm marking the end of the
over and the both umpires have moved to
move away right come on this is not the
spirit of cricket
and I just don't believe you if it was
the other way around I don't think you'd
be saying the same thing
happens every weekend in club Cricket in
Australia I don't know what you do here
it's not up to Johnny Bear so to decide
where or when it and over ends it's up
to Johnny basto to respect the the laws
of cricket which were written by the
English and to stay in his crease until
it's safe to get out of that crease if
he wants to get out of that crease while
the ball is live He's fair game I'm
sorry
I think your country's kind of lost its
mind over this and I reckon it's a bit
of a smoke screen to be honest you two
nil down in the ashes you've all been
sort of doing handstands about this this
great new brand of cricket you could
play baseball and good on you it's
fantastic it's exciting Cricket but
it's face planted in the ashes you two
nil down and you're carrying on about a
flies back on a Pulpit well we should
have won an edge but I don't understand
what's going on
we should have won an ashbastian and if
Ben Stokes catches lion when he's on two
it's all over and secondly in this last
test match if you hadn't basically
divvied out or Alberto we'd have won
that match too so we probably would have
been tuned to love
you know um you talk about the spirit of
Cricket the spirit of cricket talks
about accepting the authority of the
umpires of creating a positive
atmosphere in the way you play I mean I
find I I think that English cricketers
owes Australia an apology
is Mother's yes but you just said
yourself
that absolutely
well that I agree with absolutely okay
from your members and from the public
and it's being and it's being spent by
your team attempting to cover up let me
respond the fact that it lost it's two
nil down let me respond I agree that the
behavior of the members chanting cheat
cheat was wrong they shouldn't have done
it and that is ungracious but the idea
you as an Australian are going to
lecture us on the way crowds treat the
opponents I was at the ashes in 2013-14
where obeying mob with literally bang
for blood and in fact they were being at
one stage from my blood against Brett
Lee so I won't say any elections from
you law on how crowds behave
our crowds behave poorly too but we're
not claiming to set the standards and
I'll tell you what our crowds haven't
been jostling jostling players
did you know Steven Smith
I want to thank you for coming on
because very few others would come on I
appreciate it the ashes is now
incendiary headingley will be an avatar
a new lot are going down 3-2 thank you
for coming on Peter Layla star shopping
whatever you're up to Keep It Uncensored
and Johnny bairstow go get 100 Henning
wing
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]